hey thanks for turning in to another
episode of left to be talked today is
February 11th a Thursday bonus episode
and this episode is brought to you by
Earthquaker devices that's right if you
play guitar bass keyboards anything any
kind of instrument plug it in get crazy
you want to sound like a guitar god
get yourself a stompbox from Earthquaker
devices calm they've been my sponsor
prefer over two years and these guys
kick ass you want to sound like a king
on the guitar earthquake or devices get
it on there
tell them i Sencha get yourself a good
deal man these guys are fantastic
handmade pedals right out of Akron Ohio
do not miss them get a boutique pedal
from Earthquaker devices
all right let's get the episode going
here it's a special episode today coming
out on a Thursday
sometimes we released the [ __ ] in
episodes but a couple days ago I got a
call that I could get the mighty Yngwie
Malmsteen on the podcast and I was like
holy [ __ ] that's an epic epic guest and
I want to thank Peter Hudson for helping
me get him on met to be talk and also in
BAE's wife who was very kind to set this
up in bay he phoned in from Miami it was
a rare rare phone interview but I'll
take what I can get you don't get to
hear from Yngwie that much so when you
do it's like whatever it takes let's do
it he was promoting an incredible thing
he has coming up called the guitar gods
and that's gonna be February 19th in
Miami so if you live out there go see
Steve Vai inve Nicko McBrain is gonna be
playing Rudy Sarzo all kinds of great
stuff go to his website eating vey
Malmsteen calm and he has the whole
thing there it was an interesting
interview I was trying to keep Mon as
long as I could I didn't know how long I
was gonna have Yngwie on it wasn't
discussed so I had a whole you know
whole idea of what I wanted to ask him
and then I could tell it was it was
going to be let's let's get some
questions as fast as we could but we got
a good solid 30 out of them which is
awesome
and so I wanted to share it with you
guys right away and if you if you know
anything about guitar this guy is
absolutely the top well I mean it's
Hendrix
it's it's Eddie it's Randy Rhoads and
Yngwie those are really the ones that as
far as like completely taking guitar to
another level if you talk to Yngwie he's
probably gonna say it's me and then it's
me and then it's me and me his
full-blown confident he
a rock star he is a badass and this
episode is very very entertaining it was
to me
I've loved asking him stuff before I do
go today
I'm in Cheyenne Wyoming with the mighty
bill burr so if you're coming to the
show please get here early I am the
feature tonight and I can't even [ __ ]
wait I am jonesing to hit the stage and
work with Bill burr I just love hanging
out with them and this is gonna be
awesome
we are also in Denver tomorrow night
Friday night so hope to see you and then
I'm back Saturday for the incredible
inspirations clothing show if you live
in LA go see this inspirations if you're
into denim leather boots motorcycles
vintage clothes anything head down to
inspirations it's downtown and I believe
you can find it online inspiration calm
it's an incredible show and also I just
want to thank everybody for all the
amazing tweets please please leave
reviews and subscribe on iTunes that's
how this thing gets kicking ass thanks
everybody keep the candles lit here he
is in vain mom stain hello I had a
mountain scene I'm cause dude yeah buddy
how are you man it's this Dean Del Rey
great to hear from a man okay
so such a such a great guest i I go way
back with envy Malmsteen you you
yourself my friend I remember I'm a
friends with Mike Varney and I yeah I
saw that first time you played at
Wolfgang's with anvil chorus you
remember that that was a jam yeah yeah
oh my god 35 years ago
yeah like 1982 or something right yeah
now now what do you what do you remember
about that because it was pretty faint
with me I remember that I remember that
we hadn't been rehearsing
and you know at the time I was very very
particular young man I wanted everything
be exact and they didn't really see that
feels good you know because I think that
was a haunting to didn't listen it was
35 years I don't really remember that
much about it
yeah exactly I remember that you came in
and you started playing and immediately
I was like wow what the [ __ ] man this
guy I couldn't boy I couldn't believe it
because I asked Mike Varney and my
father and I go way back and I had him
on the show I asked him when he first
heard the demo tape when you sent it to
shrapnel I asked him if he thought that
if it was fake because the plane was
incredibly fast it was really it was it
felt speeded up and you know and and
then there you were doing it in front of
me and I was like oh my god this guy
really plays like that I remember I
remember
no insane now now when you're first
starting playing guitar back then how do
you come up or do you think you're the
first guy that did the sweet picking and
that kind of stuff how do you come up
with that well first of all the sweet
picking accurate term but what I did was
I learned to play I was very very young
was five years old my god first to talk
and I learned to play the blues no staff
and it was you know I felt a little
limited to me so my older brothers
sisters play all the Tchaikovsky we
found in everything ya know or not and
then I started learning those passages
and eventually I listened to on Hagen II
me quite famous 19th century violinist
and I heard something in there that I
wanted to apply to the next guitar which
is impossible you can't do our first of
all right but I took him in like the
inspiration from there you know which is
which is a completely opposite from
regular rock it's all playing
it's a totally different technique and
it's sort of violin technique that I
applied to it you know that's where it's
kind of wonderful you know I took it
from there you know it's love that clean
clean like fluid sound of the violin and
you know rather than just like a fuzzy
old tour you know have all that it's
just mind boggling because I mean if you
if you really look at it you have
Hendrix then you have Eddie and and
Randy Rhoads and then it's you and after
you
it stops there's no like guy after you
you know everybody just you know they
all send their their scalp and the frets
they're you know they're playing exactly
like you but not as good but if that
becomes the standard for like 10 years
straight everybody just you know going
for that well yeah I don't know you
trying to say I'm just kind of always
kind of like March them all and drum you
know I mean I always did what I felt was
good that wasn't really paying too much
attention to what people doing but I see
your point yeah yeah I mean and you
definitely marched your own drum that's
what I love about you I love rock stars
you know rock stars are definitely gone
now they're they don't exist and I and I
think that you still carry the torch
which is amazing still wear leather
pants you got long hair you got amazing
moves you use Marshalls there's that you
know your your your rock and roll and I
love that you know it yeah it's it's
it's a lot of people you can't see that
anywhere when you go on you [ __ ] have
the fire still thank you I saw video you
recently where you had like a hundred
marshals on stage it was unbelievable
how many you got up there well depending
on what gig and doing but uh you know if
I'm playing out somewhere where that the
motor split up a huge like 30 adds and
like 18 cabinets but I had bright very
moments like 40 something has and you
know it's just massive ridiculous amount
of marshals
I was out of the marshals little kid I
remember when I came to for girls kid I
read they were really expensive and then
they came out with a volleyball model
and all of a sudden that plexi wants
that the forum for the ones being very
cheap which is obviously not opted you
know they're very expensive now right
but I thought I saw my opening there so
I just bought up like 15 bucks 30 bucks
per head you know and so I bought
suppose that to when I was a little kid
you know so it became a habit from that
point on I never used anything else you
know something below a lot of guys to be
usually different things I was Marshalls
yeah because even through the whole
boutique amp phase of like matchless and
bad cat and all that point-to-point hand
wired stuff you stuck with Marshalls all
the way through absolutely yeah that
Marshall is to me is 100% rock there's
nothing else I just saw ac/dc on Friday
night same thing just a wall of
Marshalls as soon as you see Marshalls
you know you're getting it's rock they
invented the whole thing I mean that's
really everything else just because of
it right now when you're growing up and
Sweden besides violins of course you're
listening to Ritchie Blackmore and stuff
and uh Lee Roth I always hear that
everybody knows that a lot about you I
like to find out other stuffs about you
were you a guy who listened to like
ac/dc or or scorpions or like rock like
that or we just strictly like deep
purple Hendrix that kind of stuff
well actually when I first thought out
the very very young it's just little kid
mold assist again in purple record I
like the purple I like some other some
other bands like Tim baby and stuff like
that and then at one point I just
stopped listening to that this is the
only parole cluster music and you know
if I would go to a party or something
people play it easy and I liked it a lot
ATC I love them
you know but I will never like use that
as like an influence or or listen to it
you know potentially the influence was
strictly baroque classical music and you
know the metal was already you know in
my DNA and I mean so this combination of
those two things that you know grew to
be what it is
absolutely why now what was it like
growing up in Sweden were you were you
playing in cover bands and stuff because
your demo that that Varney got did you
did you make that demo in 1978 I read
somewhere well now some of them work but
that the main body of that stuff was
made in 1980 and I never paying car
cover bands I never played in bands it's
always me doing my thing and then
whoever was around playing the bass or
problems and sometimes I play the bass
drums on the recordings and saying you
know again you know I was always doing
the whole thing you know yeah some it
wasn't really a scene gone on it was
very bare you know it was really nothing
going on so it was how to lead you know
yeah let's talk about so you send the
tape to Varney and he emails you
backward as he call you my Varney's kind
of a night out he'll be up all night
does he give you a call and go hey man
just [ __ ] [ __ ] is amazing you know
Rob was a soaring Guitar Player magazine
that you could sanitation I didn't think
that so gonna be in and coming out of it
I said take that 982 and I do I think
was 82 yep and then I start getting
phone calls from kids and from Night
Ranger and other bands you know and
management stuff I didn't know that was
coming along and then my father said
call up and study what we do Rob I think
you know right then eventually I came
down a deal directly with Steeler and I
laughed the whole thing you know right
right now when you're making that
Steeler record you guys do that a
prairie son I don't remember yeah I love
that man it's like that's when you know
that it's just rock and roll you're like
man I don't know that was so [ __ ]
long ago I mean that's where Varney did
most of his records you'd go up to this
farm and kind of live on oh yeah he was
he was before me I mean that's got to be
so weird to you because you're coming
from Sweden and then you're Olson you're
on this farm making a record you know it
doesn't seem very big rock and roll but
that record was fine yeah yeah now when
you're making the Steeler record are you
already in your mind like I'm out of
here
or are you digging stealer for a while
it was a very brief period I was I think
for me point I was I'd be the first gig
with them till our lab was like one monk
or something right
I mean maybe two months I mean it was
very short
yeah and so you know I like the guy
through nice guys and thing but I think
that the music was of exactly matched
right exactly
I understand from there you go to
Alcatraz of course which I saw Alcatraz
at I believe it's the same place
Wolfgang's where you played that first
thing with amal course and and that that
had to be like kind of cool you're
playing with graham bonnet right i mean
you're a big rainbow and deep purple guy
and stuff did brother he was a bit of a
he's dead good well doctor in my book
too relentless will happen because I was
also being offered to join other bands
like dutiful as I'm like that actually
on the same day and the reason I went
with a grand ballin thing was because
they didn't have me songs the inhabit
direction they're not connecting so I
just took over the whole thing you know
it became my thing and you know because
I've always been kind of like that you
know they still strong in my views and
my style you know so I didn't want to be
just playing some other people songs
right so that's rap took that and
basically took that thing over and that
last you know and yeah that's it you who
the same day you were offered to play in
UFO that's that's that's best it's the
same day now and yeah the reason they
feel more God laughing we must use not
really exactly now I guess you know how
futile something but you know I just
found was very unorganized and you know
and I didn't want to place an old
Shanker's office and stuff so so I
joined with a thing that's gonna be my
songs for the day one you know right and
that was the same database
book relentless it's very very well well
commander exact now what happened I'm
assisting right right now now let me ask
you something about when you're when
you're writing that Alcatraz record
those songs are great on there you know
I mean all right people [ __ ] love
that song the songs and also I think
that the flavor of that carries on for
kind of the rest of your career of
course the the kind of style of music
you do right of course later you go
instrumental and stuff but was a singer
a big deal to you ever or you just never
really you were just like now it's just
more about the songs in the playing
instrumental no I mean the thing is that
when I wrote songs law guitar players
don't do that but what I do when I write
songs I write all the melodies to write
even if I don't sing them if someone
else think them doesn't matter
I write the melodies for the singer you
know and the lyrics and so so that's why
you had to hear that you know being
continuous to all my albums were oh well
you're not same thing gets it because I
does man who's a singer
they sing my melodies you know and the
first so loud mostly instrumental
because the label in Japan said you want
to be insurmountable wasn't my choice
really you know oh I think I got yeah
the rising forest record yeah that
wasn't your choice to make an instrument
I neveri well not it's not initially no
but you know we will know happen without
one became right what is it that so but
that seems kind of funny thing you know
when you're looking for a singer I'm
just curious because I sang all my life
and I love certain singers do you have
singers that you that you think this is
the this style that I love like I love
Bon Scott you know but I also I also
love Rob Halford do you like a style of
singing you know is it more kind of the
Gothic of like deep purple or like Ian
Gillan is unbelievable and I love them
in the Black Sabbath born-again record
rare I know it's rare that people like
that but I
think that that records very unique
because of how great his singing is on
that do you have you always looked for
like a style of singer or do you like to
try different style singers I just
thought of the important someone to
carry my melodies you know saying right
I don't do that stuff anymore now I'm
singing myself so - I'm going back to
what I did one of those P nature seeing
myself someone leave I'll have all my
vocals on it so now I don't have to even
look for someone else
yeah about you man you're like oh hey
it's [ __ ] me and you know that's rare
to find somebody that has a vision and
and can carry that vision through most
of the times I think the problems with
rock bands are you'll have one guy who
has a vision but then he kind of loses
it and the other guys are just sitting
there waiting for that person to carry
it through you know but with you you
definitely have some like what you want
to do and you do it you know yeah
his singing is singing hard for you
because I sang and I hadn't sang in a
while and I sang last week I did this
tribute to Bon Scott and I was like man
it gets old and I know you're 52 or so
I'm 50 it gets harder as you get older
you know yeah true I mean you know I
actually put a little more work into now
they so I actually got a bit better used
before so so it's a little bit easier
actually you know you have to warm up
and softly now absolutely I mean you
know that's what the problem I didn't do
that a couple years ago I had the
problem something's happened
no it's all good now I mean it's all
good right I think a key thing to sing
and good is sleep you have to get a
sleep or eat sleep and also tonight good
warm up you know good waters good
monitors absolutely are you taking
singing lessons because that I took
singing lessons and it became really it
was great after that you know you start
to learn what you're doing what was your
first guitar that you ever bought that
you
you owned I know you placed rad only but
did you have any other style guitars
before that well the first guitar I got
was my and my birthday present my first
birthday she's persistent rustic yeah
and then my brother bought electric
guitar when I was like six or so that I
actually got from him seven which was
now nice notes like a Stratocaster
absolutely right
coffee coffee you know she write like a
similar saying you know so I was always
that sound before I was always my
guitars and eventually I got the real
thing and I mean but uh it was sort of I
mean that's again that that's more in
detail in my book synapses so what
explained all of us wanted what was the
first strat that you got was it the 72
no it's not that one right similar
similar one guitar styles of 68 start
and ending do you prefer rosewood or
maple more permeable right right now I
know you're living out in Miami you've
always kind of lived out there right wow
that's almost 30 years now what makes
you choose Miami I'm just curious over
like LA or New York because I live in LA
in New York and let me tell you for
Miami blows away yeah it's just
beautiful amazing place
but the best everything the best I love
it I'm driving driving around right now
on it what are you driving in today yeah
I know I know you had Ferraris for a
while your big Ferrari guy what do you
drive yeah Wow no [ __ ] that is awesome
I did you see the new Ferrari that came
out yesterday the new the replacement
for the Ferrari for no I love that car
it's like a four-seat Ferrari man how
many Ferraris you got you still got a
fewer just one yeah five five man what's
what do you got I got the old ones so I
think Simone explained I
you know yeah it's funny
Ferraris are through the roof now I mean
those are your those are your retirement
you know now let's go back go back away
years ago you were in a crash right yeah
yeah I hear ya I was just I was just I
was just I was I was in a crash recently
I was hit on my motorcycle and the
reason I brought it up is it's scary
right when you use like your hands and
everything to make money right did you
have such a long time ago yeah you were
pretty wild when you were younger I was
I was crazy what wild - hey are you
still wild no no no I wouldn't say so
now do you party at all anymore no not
at all nothing nothing no booze no no
wow
no did you go - did you go to rehab or
anything for that no no no nope that 10
years well that's [ __ ] awesome man
yeah eleven Wow congrats did it did it
ever get crazy low I know there's a
point where you had some some [ __ ] like
where the cops came to your house and
stuff but was there a real low spot in
your life no like that you know those
other things
no but I always kind of like just bounce
back from stuff right yeah I don't
affect on that stuff at all I don't even
think about it
yeah some people have to be able to do -
you know bounce back from it stuff like
that some people don't
as you all know right so I don't
recommend it for anybody that's bad
stuff all of its bad yeah do you know if
you know do you know about the show in
Miami
I'm separate 19 but what's the show in
Miami are we doing this really really
great fast
yep and it's called guitar gods festival
is in Miami Beach February 19th
yep and it's a boy
my wife came up with the whole concept
and it's full called guitar gods and
it's actually in conjunction with AMF
which is a pronouncing foundation my
wife's foundation yep and is it for
awareness and protection of endangered
Alamo animals so the proceeds go to that
but it's put together as a great thing
first of all we can have having interest
like me taxi by yeah
Gus Gus G yeah Sarzo oh Rudy
Nick I'm at Green yep and then we have a
bunch of kids that I've submitted that
we've got literally thousand submissions
when we announced that we have uh if you
if you get you know we didn't eat that
you know out of a selection of so many
you get a spot to actually play on stage
with us
Wow so there's gonna be 10 10 winners
that's gonna be playing one song each so
so like I could have like a competition
for that that's amazing whoever wins
whoever wins dad that gets to go on the
on the rock to roll Bruce that goes the
next morning Wow
now is there any agent anchors was there
an age limit for the kids that audition
H limit you know I mean it can't be like
real professional recording you're right
not like this but trust me was a lot of
good submissions a lot of them so that's
gonna be great and W amphitheater right
on the beach here Mary
Wow and it is a liqueur have you yeah
semi outdoors like I am theatre so I own
a beach and February 19th and it's gonna
be amazing so anybody hears this shoot
doesn't show up you know wow that's so
cool
now no how long have you known Rudy Rudy
has been on my show a few times I'm Rudy
just played with me last week we did the
tribute to Bon Scott Rudy is an absolute
God right
yeah yeah he's great I've known him for
ages
I know whatever well whatever you tell I
know Steve seems like this I hope when I
left out started showing that so moving
forever right Steve I where were you a
big fan of the Steve Vai era of the
Zappa stuff did you listen to that stuff
at all I had some of that we Early's a
part from like this early seventies Bob
buses thought I was funny stuff yeah but
I've never you know I never really got
it heavily into anyone did you that
those funny
the lyrics are amazing yeah yeah that's
where I think that Steve Vai era of with
David Lee Roth is unbelievable it's just
next yeah that edom a smile record is
just [ __ ] phenomenal I had Derek
Sherinian on my show he's an old friend
of mine I've known him 25 years he told
me one of the funniest stories of when
you guys played I believe in Brazil it
was after 9/11 do you remember this all
right yeah he said he said that you were
playing the national anthem like in in
the middle of solos it was awesome I
love that just gangster outlaw of you
now let me ask you something are you I'm
a stand-up comedian now what do you do
when you're not listening to music do
you ever check out any comedy do you
like movies and stuff like that yeah you
know whatever lately I've been so busy
and with all sorts of stuff that she's
involved with this show and everything
like that
so I'm not as much time but yeah TV you
know yeah yeah do you ever go see
stand-up comedy that would be I would
lose my mind
Yngwie was in the front house there come
here like unleash the fury you know
[ __ ] awesome I actually got to see
the late great Sam Kinison Oh awesome so
you were around back in the 80s in LA
and where did you see Sam at The Comedy
Store not for me in New York
Wow do you remember what it was like I
think it was the Beacon Theatre
Wow what was that like he was the
greatest you know really really really
good man you know and so you were you
were a big fan or did you just happen to
be there one night and somebody said
well it was a definitely a fan because I
yeah I his HBO thing was amazing if it
was a funny thing I'm saying yeah did
you fall
did you fall comedy after that we're
into like Andrew Dice and all that stuff
yeah yeah and and anybody else like or
just the big guys of the 80s most of the
ones that come to mind right right I got
ya
I've just asked him because I think a
lot of comedy has a lot in common with
with like Twain lead guitar you know
you're up there you're riffing you've
got kind of your your act and you're
going in and out you know it's like a
freestyle thing you know yeah of course
and there's definitely comedy when
you're cruising around America and a
tour bus with a band there's no nothing
funnier than that [ __ ] right oh man so
amazing now can you talk a little bit
about the g3 tour did you have fun on
that yeah that was a lot of fun actually
great you think you're gonna do
something like that again or maybe take
this guitar gods thing on the road yeah
we'll be thinking about that think about
that
that'd be great right exactly yeah
but they think the one thing we're doing
now is definitely like that you know
that will be like the one definitely the
star of the whole thing because the
guitar goes we doing now I know right
they'll take from there I'm saying yeah
as a lot of big names out there actually
calling us and they want to do it too
you know so it's got a lot of interest
in it that'd be awesome man who are some
of the newer players that you like do
you like anybody out there that you hear
you know I don't really have you know an
active like active in it check it out so
I couldn't do it value but I mean I know
there's a lot of new kids out there yeah
but I couldn't really mention
it's pretty I think it's kind of easier
now right they just fire on YouTube and
they learn how to play the songs yeah I
guess so yeah yeah I mean back in the
day yeah back in the day you're in
Sweden you don't got YouTube you gotta
slow the record down and go back and
forth and listen to it right yeah right
I mean that's how you imagine trying to
learn Blackmore like that I mean it's
just like it takes years yeah yeah I
want to thank you for coming on the show
and longtime longtime fan man and I hope
I hope to see you in LA soon are you
gonna be out here soon I don't know
thank you my song view don't forget
February 19th Miami Beach February 19th
man guitar gods thank you brother
exactly thank you light the candles
you